I'm going to try to answer some of the
questions that you all sent in about the
conflict in Ukraine
[Music]
things will only change in this war when
things change in the Kremlin everyone
therefore is asking you know will there
be a coup against Putin there are no
signs of it at the moment there are
tensions in the crime we know about that
but there always are and it's impossible
to say Putin might disappear in two
months time or it might be five years
time but it won't be a popular revolt
against him it will be a coup somewhere
among the silhou the security people
that the military the security people
the people very close to him the
siliviki that Elite of people around him
only about 20 or 30 of them sooner or
later they will actually remove him uh
at in some way or another I'm sure about
that just don't know when
foreign
is quite likely to be surrounded it's
almost surrounded now I don't think the
city itself will collapse to the
Russians but if it is surrounded then
the ukrainians will simply have to
withdraw and I think we're getting to
that point very soon unless they can
push back I don't really think they can
at this stage
for as long as Ukraine is determined to
fight against Russian invasion they
shouldn't have that much of a Manpower
problem because the ukrainians are a big
country of 44 million people they have
mobilized apparently about a million
certainly seven hundred thousand now and
another three hundred thousand to come
and they could mobilize another million
if they had to they've got a vigorous
young male population which is more than
the Russians of golf although the
Russian population is three times bigger
so I think the ukrainians if they have
to dig deep we'll find that they do have
a depth of Manpower Manpower that they
can really use as well as the women in
Ukraine who are also pretty determined
to fight
it's impossible to see this War ending
as a conflict in the sense that as long
as the Russians believe that Ukraine has
no right to exist and as long as the
Ukraine's ukrainians themselves are
determined to fight for their existence
then this war will go on but it is
possible that there will be ceasefires
there may be a ceasefire sometime this
year there will be unstable ceasefires
and I would expect this war to as we go
through a series of ceasefire fighting
ceasefire fighting for the indefinite
future until things more fundamentally
change inside Russia
the old status quo is gone that will
never come back there is no retreat from
this there's no turning back there's no
hiding from it European security has
changed fundamentally as a result of the
Russian invasion last year we now have
to live with the prospect that Ukraine
will always be threatened by its bigger
neighbor and Ukraine will have to be a
heavily armed State living with Western
Security guarantees we hope in peace but
there will always be tension for the
next 50 or 60 years between Ukraine and
Russia whatever the outcome of the
present fighting is
the Russians are putting lots of
Manpower into the front not very
well-trained troops not very well
equipped troops but in very high numbers
they seem to have about 300 000 troops
now deployed across the battle space
ukrainians are fighting a more
western-style war they're not going in
for human wave attacks and they're using
better techniques and better weapons
against them but they haven't got enough
they haven't got enough heavy Weaponry
they're getting more but it hasn't yet
arrived in sufficient numbers to make a
difference so the ukrainians having done
well in the Autumn are now holding
they're holding this Russian push to buy
themselves time to get their better
weapons and newly organized forces
together in order to try to push the
Russians back so this sense of of
stalemate is not really the the essence
of the problem it's it's a pause before
things start to happen in a big way
the weapons that have been given to
Ukraine are given uh there's no sense
that they're being leased or purchased
by the ukrainians the question of what
happens to them afterwards
um really is a is a subject for another
day as far as Ukraine is concerned
um many of those weapons of course will
be destroyed before the end of the
fighting most weapon systems only last a
matter of weeks or months before they're
knocked out or they're so overused that
they have to be completely refurbished
so I think the weapons that are donated
to Ukraine will stay in Ukraine
um and they will they will simply as it
will need more weapons as the years go
on even in peace they will need a lot of
Weaponry
um and a lot of support in order to
maintain their independence against the
state Russia under Putin that is
determined to crush them
ukrainians need time at the moment they
need time to get this new equipment
which is being sent to them organized
into battalions and then armored
brigades if they can do that then they
have a choice they can either use them
to try to push in luhans can push the
Russians back into donbass which is
where the essence of the the battle
looks as if it's going to take place
this year or if they don't need it for
that if they can hold in the dombas
without using these new forces they
could use them to push South to Melita
Paul on the coast and open up a new
front which will really give the
Russians something to worry about and
will threaten Crimea and that's
strategically quite important because if
the ukrainians can threaten Crimea even
if the Russian threatened Kiev there
will be something there to bargain with
but it rather depends on how long it
takes the ukrainians to get their new
equipment and their new units together
into a fighting force we'll find out
within about a month I think
thank you
Moldova is a very vulnerable state
smallest second poorest state in Europe
right on the edge of Ukraine on the
western edge and the Russians have
always played games in Moldova and
moldova's getting plenty of political
support from the European Union and some
encouragement from NATO but nobody wants
to put Western troops into Moldova to
support the government everyone is
hoping that Moldova can get through the
political crisis which the Russians are
trying to manufacture on the 19th of
February the Russian minority in Moldova
called a major demonstration to try to
remove the government it failed
miserably and so there is some Prospect
perhaps the government of Moldova led by
the female president and a very good new
prime minister
ex-economics Minister might be able to
get through the next few months